I'm never saying like go do this right
I'm saying like here are some things out
there be self like my it's easy for me
because I'm not looking for absolutes
I'm not like you need to buy real estate
in Texas right I'm saying things like
are you self-aware do you know what you
like are you reverse engineering
strengths and interests here are some
macro Trends there's things going on on
Tik Tok uh I'll give one right now Tik
Tock live is a
beast is how is a beast howwi he right
now if you went on Tik Tok live for
three hours a day yeah you would be
flabbergast you should do the you should
do the ooh like you know the girls that
do like every time they get a gift they
do like a different
move you saying you want him to do an
only fans
or that's not only fans she's talking
about I know the digital Gifts of course
I know what she's listen but what are
you saying I'm just saying this for the
whole audience of entrepreneurs and you
included Tik Tok so the way I see the
world is there are moments in time where
tension on a platform is misunderstood
or were underestimated okay 1980s HBO
standup special yeah TRL on MTV in the
9s right um what I do for a living five
years ago Tik Tok or email marketing in
1997 how I built my Daddy's Liquor Store
okay so I'm always watching for
underpriced distribution in media
Landscapes right the current one as we
sit here this second is Tik Tok live for
three because I'll go on Tik Tok live a
lot but I I you know I'll spend a half
hour
the longer the better because the way
that algo is working and the way I'm
seeing it from my perch is Tik Tok is
really testing their live product and
they're helping more exposure for the
people that are committing more to the
platform so the longer you're on it
you're growing unlike a platform like
Instagram live where you go on and you
can see the audience dip right because
all they're doing is informing your
entire audience and then everyone comes
and then a percentage goes away what Tik
tok's doing is you go live and it's
showing up in the algorithms and people
are discovering
you wow can I go on Tik Tok live now no
let's not let's not
why